- Companies in the S&P 500
are on pace to buy back
more than $1 trillion worth
of their own stock this year,
a record high.
Warren Buffett recently
defended stock buybacks,
or at least insisted that
they're not always bad,
but these companies are buying
record amounts of their stock
at a time when investors are
largely selling their shares.
I'm going to explain why
companies are buying back
their stock right now,
what stock buybacks are and
how they benefit corporations,
and why this could be a risky gamble
for some of the market's big names.
Let's get into it.
Goldman Sachs recently
authorized $30 billion
of planned stock buybacks,
and Facebook parent Meta announced plans
to buy $40 billion of their own stock.
This might sound like
an odd use of capital
given that these companies'
stock prices have sunk
and they've recently announced
thousands of layoffs.
Data show that both
institutional investors
and retail investors
have been selling stock
in recent weeks.
But companies like to buy back
stock during market selloffs
for a number of reasons.
First, seeing the company
buy signals to investors
that management still sees
the stock as attractive.
It shows they're putting
some skin in the game.
Second, with growing
uncertainty in the market,
investors are saying
buybacks are what they want.
Bank of America's latest
Global Fund Manager Survey
shows the percentage of investors
who want companies to
return cash to shareholders
is at the highest since 2017.
Third, the latest earnings
results show S&P 500 companies
are generating lower net profits
and seeing their pricing power decline.
By purchasing their own stock,
companies can improve their
earnings per share numbers,
making the stock more
attractive to investors.
When you calculate earnings per share,
lower earnings don't look so
bad if there are fewer shares.
It's also important to note
that top executives' pay
packages are often tied
to the company's stock price.
So a higher stock price often
means more money for CEOs
and others who decide how to
deploy a company's capital.
But what are stock buybacks,
and why do companies do
them in the first place?
When companies go public,
they sell shares to anyone who wants them.
When companies buy back their stock,
they literally buy available shares
from market makers or
individual shareholders.
Buybacks have historically
increased a stock's price
because, as our economics
textbook teaches us,
when supply decreases and
demand stays the same,
prices typically rise.
But buybacks are not without their risks.
Big companies like Meta and
Goldman have lots of cash
on their balance sheets,
but others could run into
some serious trouble.
With interest rates rising,
it will be much more expensive
for companies to borrow money.
Some firms could find
themselves running outta cash,
while still needing to pay employees,
vendors, and suppliers.
That could create a cash crunch
where companies have to sell off assets
or declare bankruptcy.
So when companies announce
buybacks, some investors buy
because it usually means
the price will be rising,
but some sell because it can also mean
that the company is getting desperate
and has more concern with its stock price
than with investing in the company itself.
(upbeat music)